hey what's up guys it's Marquez from the
mkbhd Channel and here it is this is it
this is what I've been waiting for for a
long time and what you may have been
waiting for it's the Verizon LTE Samsung
Galaxy Nexus and I walked home with this
phone with the biggest grin on my face
and I'm just gonna take out the box
because I don't really want to spend too
much time if you can see here it very
subtly says Verizon and Galaxy Nexus so
that's great and on the back it also
gives us a list of features including
basically what comes in the box but this
is off to the side
I know unboxings aren't the most
exciting thing in the world but I will
be getting a lot of hands-on time with
this phone so literally thumbs up and
anything you want to see on this phone
let me know in the comments because oh
it's red it's Verizon red anything you
want to see let me know what you want to
see about this phone and there she is
damn that's a big screen now note that I
am coming from a returning from a 3.7
inch screen that looks fingerprint D
from the original Motorola Droid so this
is a huge upgrade for me I was tweeting
furiously from that phone as I was
waiting in line but yeah there was a
line for this phone and here it says
Galaxy Nexus on the interior of the box
I'm gonna put that to the side here and
that is just so now that's pretty that's
actually pretty it's beautiful so here
on the back it says Verizon 4G and it's
telling us we can pop this off oh and
I'll probably take that off later now
just so you guys know I did choose to
protect this device just a little bit
got some screen protectors I probably
won't be using a case at all of this I
like my phone like I like my woman yeah
okay so we'll move on and I think there
are some more accessories we have to
look at this is empty and here we go so
we have what appears to be a gigantic
user manual this is master your device
Galaxy Nexus and there's three booklets
in here so I'm assuming yep there's more
than one language alright so I have some
literature to read as if I don't already
I'm finally I also have our headphones
and these are the headphones that come
with the Galaxy Nexus and only with the
Galaxy Nexus so these look good I'm
gonna try these out
don't use headphones with my phone but
when I do I'm listening to music and I'm
using the m50 s right here we have our
USB cable for connecting to our computer
and charging probably only for charging
because I never connect phones to the
computer and last but not least our wall
adapter but that's not the star of the
show obviously the star of the show is
sitting right here in the Galaxy Nexus
which still has a screen protector on
but I'm gonna fire it up anyway by
pressing this that looks pretty
we have 720p screen this is the first
boot of my Galaxy Nexus and we're gonna
go ahead and zoom in as it boots up and
show you the blue animation which is oh
so pretty and so you guys remember the
specs this is running a 1.2 gigahertz
dual-core processor has the same GPU as
the Nexus S it has a gig of ram and it's
running Android 4.0 it has a beautiful 4
point 65 inch 720p display as you can
see Android was upgrading just there
which is kind of cool interesting of
course so yeah ice cream sandwiches
Android Android 4.0.4
it is already activated so the beauty of
that is it's already pulling in my
emails and we're gonna go ahead and take
a first look oh it already installed
some apps that's crazy
so we're gonna go ahead and take a look
at the launcher for the first time look
at that full 4G by the way that's
beautiful so make yourself at home
to see all your apps touch here sure ooh
to add an app to your home screen touch
to drag touch and hold it I'll put it
right there that's pretty and also I'm
gonna go ahead and open a launcher here
look at that that is Android 4.0 free
it's installing all the apps from my
gmail account so without any further ado
go ahead and leave your comments down
below what do you guys want to see about
this phone I am so excited for every
aspect of the Samsung Galaxy Nexus
thanks for watching this screen is so
nice um and talk to you guys later
face